في يونيو عام
1991 ثار بركان جبل بينا طوبو في الفلبين
ادى ثورانه الى اطلاق اطنان من الرماد
والغاز صوب الغلاف الجوي ما اسفر عن تبريد
الارض بنحو نصف درجه مئويه بكل تاكيد الهم
التجربه البركان الفلبيني العلماء ورجال
الاعمال الكبار وفي مقدمتهم بتمويل مشروع
يتمحور حول اطلاق بالون ضخم ينشر غبار
الطباشير في طبقه
لتعتيم الشمس بالقرب من مدينه كيرونا في
القطب الشمالي هناك طروحات مغايره لحجب
الشمس تقوم على استخدام مراوح عملاقه يتم
تثبيتها على سطح القمر لاطلاق الغبار
لبقعه تتوسط الارض والشمس ليصنع من هذه
الكميه من الغبار درع حامل للارض هناك من
فكر في اطلاق الرماد بمنجنيق او تشكيل سور
من المرايا او الالومنيوم لعكس اشعه الشمس
اما الرافضون يعتقدون ان هذه الافكار
تلاعب مع البيئه
وستسبب تلويث المحيطات بالغبار الكبريتي
وقد تسرع من سيناريو تحويل الارض الى جليد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]